[Music]
okay Simon how does this work all right
once the dead man is revived we can ask
him five questions at which point he
will die again never to be re-revived
five five questions I don't know that's
just how it works
it seems arbitrary can we get on with
this place right yes
maybe I'm not saying it
I wasn't scared nearly startled
here we go
were you killed in the battle of the
Amber horse
yes great I mean
not for you sorry for your loss one more
question right yes no no that wasn't for
you did that count as a question yes
damn it
only answer when I talk to you okay yes
why did you say Okay at the end of that
I didn't
foreign
[Music]
Dungeons and Dragons
thank you
[Music]